everyone continues to talk about various
technologies and financial assets during
this conflict between russia and ukraine
but what you have to remember is that
there are millions and millions of
people on the ground that simply don't
want to be in danger whether they're
talking about their children their
spouse their friends or their family
they simply want to get out of that
danger zone and so they're fleeing
ukraine to various other sectors what we
see here is whether they're going to
poland slovenia hungary romania or
somewhere else people are doing the
absolute best that they can to get out
of the country to get to safety now of
course if you are simply going to pick
up on a moment's notice and leave as you
can see here in kiev or elsewhere and
get into a car walk get on public
transportation leave everything you've
ever known behind immediately you start
to think how will i bring as much as i
can but still be able to get to safety
but that's not possible in the country
right now what we see here is that atms
aren't working there's not enough money
in the bank look at the crowd that
gathered as more and more people stand
in line and they realize they're not
going to be able to get their economic
value out as more people realize they're
not going to be able to get their money
out we start to understand the
importance of a digital decentralized
currency it's not just used for
censorship resistant it's also used to
be able to hold on to the economic value
that you've earned that you've saved and
that you continue to want to have
regardless of where you are in the world
if you can simply store economic value
in a digital decentralized currency you
can take it with you in a moment's
notice it's the beauty of bitcoin is
that it's a neutral technology it can be
used by friend or a foe but ultimately
the people on the ground in ukraine they
don't have to worry about having some
assets confiscated at a border they
don't have to worry about the dangers of
taking everything to their name with
them as they run to some new country
where they know nobody maybe they don't
even know the language now instead they
can store their value in a digital way
that allows for nobody to confiscate it
nobody to debase it and that i think is
just another example of why bitcoin is
inevitable